stunning shot of Chicago there as people
isolate at home videoconferencing is the
new normal the popular abs oom says it's
numbers of users has ballooned from
about 10 million to hundreds of millions
but the FBI is warning about reports of
people intruding on calls with
pornographic or hate images our consumer
investigative correspondent and a Warner
Werner spoke with tsums CEO Anna what's
going on that's right Anthony attackers
with other agendas they've discovered
zoom to as one Long Island mother found
out earlier this month she asked us not
to use her last name or the name of her
daughter's school because she said they
now fear more online attacks mom
Michelle says her 14 year old daughter
was online in a class for her private
Modern Orthodox Girls High School when
some boys zoom bombed it first the
screens were completely black and they
were saying all these anti-semitic
things cursing and out saying you effing
Jews etc and then one boy suddenly
strict and was naked she says her
daughter was upset she was very
embarrassed by it and she just said I
can't talk about it
well the Internet brings out base
instincts it's true every new platform
wired editor and CBS News contributor
Nick Thompson says hackers are taking
advantage of the millions of new zoom
users they don't know how to security
and so suddenly they're vulnerable to
monsters want to interrupt in Sultan
zoom founder and CEO Eric UN says his
company wasn't prepared for the influx
of novice users I think this is he says
businesses using zoom typically require
employees to use passwords something
first-time users often don't do users as
well is it fair though to blame the
users doesn't the company have a
responsibility to protect
then on the front end you know given
that you guys are the experts on your
own system ample suitors right I think
that's why I say we did not do a good
job when we offer the free service we
should have a training session we should
enable the password looking back they
should have it done that
absolutely this our oversight but tell
that to Danelle Williams who heads the
National Association of real estate
brokers it's not right he had over 200
people in a zoom conference meeting
yesterday when someone hacked in and
drew a picture of male genitalia on the
screen then started making racist
comments and then the slurs I mean using
the n-word I mean I think it resumed
without a doubt people are gonna have a
few negative connotations about zoom
bombs and private speakers for a long
time with this company on the other hand
Thompson says most people still want the
service including the people we
interviewed on Zoom for this story this
was a bad experience for these children
and hopefully it won't happen again
for sure zoom CEO told us he is taking
steps to address what he calls these
unforeseen issues passwords have now
been put in place by default for
everyone and for the K through 12
schools so many thousands of whom are
now using zoom they'll use something
called the waiting room you can use that
to basically allows you to see who is
joining prior to the call and restrict
access and you can change that Anthony
in your settings yeah as you point out
Anna so many people using it we do it
for interviews my wife for conferences
my son for classes it's everywhere all
of a sudden thanks Anna